last week we sent a questionnaire to
every Republican presidential candidate
announced in potential asking about
Ukraine WE Post six questions is
opposing Russia and Ukraine a vital
strategic interest for America what's
our objective in Ukraine and how are we
going to know when we've achieved it
what is the limit of money and weapons
you'd be willing to send to zielinski
have U.S sanctions been effective and
does the United States face the risk of
nuclear war with Russia it's kind of
presumptuous for a cable show to send
these but no one else in the media
seemed to be asking them and we thought
we should
the first presidential primaries are 10
months away voters should know where
their candidates stand on the big issues
and this in some ways is the biggest
issue
so tonight we're happy to report that
virtually everyone we asked responded
Nikki Haley ignored us John Bolton said
he was too busy doing some unspecified
thing but most of the rest of us them
did get back to us and we are grateful
that they did in general the answers
were fascinating some of them were so
thoughtful and so smart they give you
hope for the Republican Party
with only a few exceptions these their
answers bore no resemblance at all to
the statements you see every day from
Mitch McConnell and various Republican
committee chairman in the Congress
Republicans in Washington tend to be
committed neocons in the Hillary Clinton
mold but Republicans running for
president this cycle generally are not
at all
that was a surprise a refreshing
surprise we had no idea we didn't know
what to think
so we're going to post every response
that we got in full on our Twitter
account tonight as a public record of
where the candidates stand on Ukraine we
hope you will look at them
but first here's a quick summary of what
we received
so former president Donald Trump who as
of tonight is the front runner for the
Republican nomination sent a long and
really interesting response Russia would
never have attacked Ukraine if I were
president he writes not even a small
chance Trump says he opposes regime
change in Russia quote we should support
regime change in the United States
that's far more important the bite
Administration the ones who got us into
this mess
Trump repeatedly refers to the risk of
nuclear war which he describes is
absolutely real and then he calls for a
negotiated Peace by Ukraine mediated by
the United States quote both sides are
weary and ready to make a deal Trump
writes the meeting should start
immediately there is no time to spare
death and destruction must end now
Trump has been saying things like this
and predicting this for five years now
and he's saying it again
what's interesting though is that
Trump's former vice president Mike Pence
was also running for president this year
opposes his old boss on nearly every
point
we're paying ukrainians to fight Russia
Pence rights so we won't have to fight
Russians ourselves
Pence endorses even stricter sanctions
against Moscow he dismisses the risk of
nuclear Wars a quote bullying tactic
from Putin and then Pence suggests that
anyone who disagrees with his views on
Ukraine is a disloyal American quote
there is no room for Putin apologists in
the Republican Party
Mike Pence did not specify who he was
talking about though we suspect this
show is included in that treasonous
category
and then maybe the most newsworthy
response that we received was from
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis DeSantis
has well-known views on many topics of
course but until tonight no one could
really say with Precision where he stood
on the war in Ukraine which is arguably
the most important topic in the world
and now we know
DeSantis is adamantly opposed to the
position that most Republicans in
Washington have taken on Ukraine
DeSantis is not a neocon who knew quote
well the U.S has many vital national
interests to santus rights securing our
borders addressing the crisis of
Readiness within our military achieving
energy security and Independence and
checking the economic cultural and
military power of the Chinese Communist
Party becoming further entangled in a
territorial dispute between Ukraine and
Russia is not one of them
without question he writes peace should
be the objective the U.S should not
provide assistance that could require
the deployment of American troops or
enable Ukraine to engage in offensive
operations Beyond its borders f-16s and
long-range missiles should therefore be
off the table
these moves would risk explicitly
drawing the United States into the
conflict and drawing us closer to a hot
war between the world's two largest
nuclear powers that risk is unacceptable
DeSantis goes on to oppose the policy of
regime change in Moscow which is very
popular in Washington and he points out
that the bite Administration has created
an alliance between Russia and China and
that's a disaster for the United States
quote we cannot prioritize intervention
in an escalating foreign war over the
defense of our own Homeland especially
as tens of thousands of Americans are
dying every year from narcotics smuggled
across our open border and our weapons
arsenals critically for our own security
are rapidly being depleted
so that's
desantis's position
clarified
Vivek ramaswamy meanwhile who you just
saw who announced for president on this
show a few weeks back responded with was
effectively an essay it was so tightly
argued and sharp it probably should be a
Wall Street Journal piece we hope it
becomes one we can't really do it
justice here but a few short excerpts
give you the flavor quote China wants
the Ukraine war to last as long as
possible to deplete Western military
capacity before invading Taiwan it's
working
we think we appear Stronger by helping
Ukraine but actually become weaker
vis-a-vis China we spent 20 years
droning people in caves in the Middle
East and Central Asia and have little to
show for it we should be taking out the
people who have caused the deaths of
more than a hundred thousand Americans
every year the Mexican drug cartels if I
were president right now I wouldn't
limit any further funding or support to
Ukraine Ukraine is not in the top five
of American foreign policy priorities
right now and yet merely questioning
whether the money we spent on the war is
being done effectively or perhaps even
prolonging the war is seen as disloyal
we get accused by both Democrats and
Republicans of being quote Putin
sympathizers the Washington uniparty and
defense contractors want this conflict
to go on forever for the sake of the
global economy and peace we should be
doing everything we can to end it
tomorrow end quote
Governor Christie gnome of South Dakota
echoed some of these points the primary
external threat to the United States is
communist China she writes and then she
added another point that you rarely hear
and not often enough quote the United
States has come to rely far too heavily
on financial sanctions as a weapon of
deterrence now the Nations that hate
America are consciously moving away from
the US dollar as the world's Reserve
currency sanctions against China Iran
and Russia have bolstered the Russian
Ruble and enabled China to establish
trade in Chinese money rather than in
U.S dollars
that is true provably true and you
wonder why so few in Congress which past
these sanctions will acknowledge it
Texas governor Greg Abbott meanwhile was
not quite so bold or precise but in
spirit he seemed to agree with most of
the rest of the Republican candidates
quote President Biden's blank check
foreign policy in Ukraine has diverted
funding from essential needs in the
United States throwing money at Ukraine
with no accountability or objective is
clearly failing end quote
once again we had no idea the candidates
felt this way until today and we're glad
they do Senator Tim Scott of South
Carolina by the way did not send a
statement but instead of transcript from
a hit he did on Trey Gowdy's weekend
show here on Fox not many details in it
but Scott did call for quote degrading
the Russian military he did not explain
what the point of that might be and
finally Chris Christie is still around
it's still full of bombast still a
sporty character in fact if anything
Christie seems to become even more
Orthodox as a neocon he calls in the US
military to fight and win a war against
both Russia and China simultaneously
otherwise he warns Iran and North Korea
could take over the world
so that is where the Republican
presidential candidates stand on Ukraine
but do not take our word for it we are
posting their answers unedited on
Twitter right now we hope you will take
a look we will read them they're
interesting whether you agree or
disagree and once again thank you to
everyone who took the time to respond in
such a thoughtful way almost all did and
we're grateful for that subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight